everyone will get started on the
Thursday of the algorithms workshop okay
okay great okay well thanks to inviting
me to participate in this workshop
there's many faces here I've not seen
before
not my usual community so maybe I'll
just say a little bit about myself so
I'm not a qualm computer scientist I
wouldn't say that I work on quantum
algorithms even though that's what's on
the top of my talk so my main area of
expertise is really in the classical
side of simulation developing class core
exams for chemistry and material science
but you know in recent times you know
it's unavoidable to have some interest
in what's going on in the quantum field
and but in any case I mean I'm here to
learn into sort of exchange ideas and I
look forward to learning from all of you
ok so so really today's talk I'm is
going to touch on a few different points
so since I'm one of the classical people
I will be telling a little bit about
what the state of the art is and
classical simulations of chemistry and
materials and and in that context I'll
give some opinion about where one might
think of or how one might think of
quadrant äj-- in this setting then I
will talk about so the two problems that
I am think about in the quantum area the
first is now given these amazing devices
that are being built for us by these
amazing institutions and companies know
can we actually use them to do a
simulation and generate that and also
that's not complete garbage you know
this doesn't seem like the highest bar
but I actually think it's quite
difficult and so I think this is what
we're going to try and do to start out
and for this I will tell you about some
of the algorithms that we've been
thinking about to execute on this
devices and maybe they'll be useful
beyond as well and then finally the
second thing that I'm thinking about
these days is a question of whether
there's any task even if it's a little
bit artificial in a chemist chemical
materials
fear where we can demonstrate
demonstrate clearly the benefit of using
a Chrome computer and this is what one
might call physical qualms supremacy and
I'll just touch on this point at the
very end okay let me go to first start
with the beginning and you know this
topic is really this this session is
really about chrome simulation and and
you know why no way shows this this
quote from Fineman it's taken from his
talk
similarly in physics with computers and
and like many of the things that phiman
said in his later years you know it's
both like very forward-looking but also
not very precise but and but in any case
it's we view this as the start of the
field and you know what's really behind
this is the sense that you know when one
is dealing with molecules or materials
no they are quantum objects in
particular you know the electrons are
very light and so you have to describe
them with cual mechanics and so in that
if one were to think about the
information to specify some arbitrary
chrome state of a molecule material then
the amount of classical information
clearly grows exponentially with the
system size so so this is the reason
behind you know the intense interest and
optimism with respect to using chrome
devices to simulate molecules so this
one side of the coin but there's another
side of the coin and that's the
following which is that if it were
really true that you needed a quantum
computer to understand anything about
molecules or materials right so in other
words if a chemists and physicists had
been weighing 300 years 4.com computer
to be built before they could say
anything about these systems then these
disciplines would not exist so so I
think understanding the role of con
computing and chemistry and mature
science is really so understanding the
tension between these two statements you
know and that's what one has to resolve
so ok so I'll begin now by showing you
some examples of simulations that one
does you know with classical techniques
which gives some insights into so where
the boundary is between these two things
are they our molecules really very hard
or are they somehow very easy ok so so
let's just first start with some small
molecules and I'll show you some data
from
and benchmarks so this was a large
collaboration with many many scientists
I'm somewhere in the middle of this
thing and we just took some small
diatomic molecules which consists of one
transition metal atom and one oxygen
atom okay so these are what we call
transition Melbourne oxides and the goal
was to solve the shirring equation as
accurately as possible for these
molecules with a variety of techniques
so immediately in this problem one sees
if one just looks if when if one just
looks at the size of the hilbert space
that one's considering in the
simulations that we did it's so
ridiculously large right so in the
largest simulations in the particular
basis now the hilbert space dimension is
ten to the forty four okay so so you
would argue that if you're just
measuring the complexity of the molecule
by the potential size of the hilbert
space that you could inhabit you know
this is something that's impossible but
in reality one can do quite well right
so this is a a correlation plot of the
estimates of the exact energies from a
variety of different methods in
particular these three methods here are
considered to be exact in the sense that
there's some parameter where if you keep
pushing it you'll get to the right
answer if you put enough effort in and
you know it's color-coded
I don't know how clear it is but these
off diagonal elements show you how close
these estimates are and this is in a log
scale so these bars means that the
relative their the difference between
the estimator energy between these two
methods is less than so one ten to the
minus three atomic units so they're very
very close okay the base essentially
exact now is that a large number or a
small number I mean you know you have to
be in the field to really know total
energies are not an observable quantity
of a molecule but what is observable in
a molecule what you can measure by
experiments are relative energies the
dissociation energy for example is a
difference of two energies and so we can
compare these predictions to compute it
to the measured experimental
dissociation energies and I'm sorry for
the resolution of this plot it it just
noticed this just now but here are three
methods taken from this table they
produce three estimates or the
dissociation energies
this one has some statistical noise
that's why it's presented as a band and
it's plotted against the experimental
measurements so the experimental Mensch
measurements are these dots here as a
function of time
okay functional year so experiment
itself is a shifting targets a moving
target you notice that the measurement
is changing over time but the spread of
the experimental results is in fact
larger than the spread of the
theoretical estimates and so what one
can say from this study is that in small
molecules you know the best methods
agree to tend to match the atomic units
is 1 milli Hartree and this is a small
number in the sense that it's as
accurate or more accurate then you can
get from an experiment ok so one might
say ok this is a small molecule even
though there's a large hilbert space but
maybe it's it's simple because it's
small so one can try and do something
that's more complicated look at larger
molecules a more complex chemistry oh
yes well of course we can't simulate an
infinite space in any simulation so yes
the hilbert space is actually infinite
yes yes that is a continuum problem I'm
just showing the large at the best
largest discretization we use a 44 right
this isn't yeah yeah we actually
disguised it this is the size of this
place yeah yeah it's actually infinite
in reality this is yes yeah this is the
we are approximating infinity by this
moment yeah so one can look at you know
perhaps our more complex systems and you
know one example of a complex system
that I see appears to be known in this
field in the computing field this
nitrogenase okay so nitrogenase is an
enzyme that well it takes atmospheric
nitrogen converted to ammonia it's very
important in the biological nitrogen
cycle it's really actually two pieces of
this I've just chopped it in half and
there are these three Center Central
machines in this cluster which are which
in this enzyme which underneath iron
sulfur clusters so there's this piece
the P cluster and this cluster here and
you know these systems are considered to
be kind of complicated to simulate
because the traditional wisdom is that
transition metals are relatively
complicated chemical objects and so if
you were to take a system which has many
transition metals then it must be
complicated and the example and biology
of a system which has the most
transition metals that's doing something
interesting is this protein here is this
enzyme here and so I think for that
reason you know in this I think very
well-known paper by the Microsoft group
I suppose you know nitrogenase
understanding the electronic structure
of nitrogenases describes it's a killer
rap for chrome computer but though it's
true that this system is very
complicated you know it's not the case
that one can't actually do anything
classically or that one doesn't have any
classical understanding of the system
and so you know here's an example of a
calculation on the P cluster this second
cluster here where one computes the
various excited states that involved in
the chemistry of the system and here the
energies that one obtains and the
energies that one gets are not you know
the the errors are not as small as in
the last case because the molecule is
much bigger I mean they're roughly ten
times as large but I can do a little bit
extrapolation and so on and get some
estimates which are now again back on
the ten to the minus three scale okay so
so that means that you know even in
these very complicated systems you know
at least semi-quantitative insight is
possible and then finally I would just
say a little bit about materials I mean
it could show lots and lots of these
slides often when one's talking about
the physics of correlated materials one
talks about them in terms of models
perhaps in those famous model is the
hubbard model nowadays I guess people
call the fermi hubbard model and this is
a simple Hamiltonian which has a
parameter in it which controls the
strength of the Coulomb interaction and
if you simulate this model and you
change this parameter around and you
change the density of particles in the
model so you change the number of
particles entering into it then it's
believed to produce at least although
typically seen phases electronic faders
that you have in materials that you can
make okay
so so people have some understanding of
the complexity of this model in the
sense that they know that for certain
parameter regimes and certain densities
it's kind of difficult to get a very
good answer and so one way to see how
well we understand or how well we can
simulate things is to try and just take
these most difficult points and that's
something that always I was going to say
people
Mentalist study this as well in quantum
simulations
so one thing we did was looked at the
Hubbard model wannabes this with cool
points at this one AIDS doping point
this is a paper which is mainly about
the physics at at this point but there's
a lot of numerical data so we can use it
to extract some benchmarks and when
Steve that by applying all these very
variety of methods one can get some
agreement in the total energy of the
system within an air above about a half
percent so that represents this of
accuracy with which we understand some
of the most difficult materials models
today it's half a percent to one percent
a big or small number well it depends on
what you're interested in so you know if
I translate this into temperature for a
material described by this model such as
it's a qubit material then that's a
temperature of about thirty Kelvin and
so physics that is on scales that's
smaller than three Kelvin will not be
resolvable but there's a lot physics on
scales there's a larger than three
Kelvin then that can they'll be excess
okay so so from these slides I think
it's clear that so the right way to
measure complexity in chemical material
systems is not the size of the hilbert
space that's a solver to naive a metric
instead when one's thinking about all
these different classical simulation
methods there are many other axes of
complexities that one use and the reason
why there's so many different acronyms I
showed on those slides which I didn't
explain you know these are all different
classical techniques it's because they
have different performance and different
actually they have different so they get
two different points on these various
the axes of complexity by which you can
describe different problems so some
examples and this won't be exhaustive is
you know you could classify problems by
the dimensionality there are many
methods that just work in all dimensions
equally well but there are also many
methods that are particularly good only
in certain dimensions you know some
methods you know actually don't scale at
all with the dimension right some
methods are particularly efficient in
one dimension some methods work in all
dimensions
similarly you might you know think about
problems on the in in terms of how much
order there is in the quantum state you
know how close the correlations are in
some sense to classical diagrammatic
methods typically work very very well
Fireman diagrams when you close to an
ordered state and they break down as a
system
becomes frustrated you know if you're
someone who likes random numbers then
you know you want those random numbers
to all come out the same sign right to
be doing Monte Carlo so you don't have a
lot of variance and so in that setting
decide that magnitude the sign problem
is very important in defining the
complexity of the system and then you
know another axis is how realistic your
model is so there are many methods which
work really well in a sense they produce
very accurate solutions of the shirring
equation but that's only for
hamiltonians are these they're only
practical to apply the hamilton doesn't
have many terms in it and if you want to
do with more realistic systems than you
might use choose use methods which don't
give it as an exact solution assuring
equation but can deal with lots and lots
of terms okay so what is illustrates is
at least the way we think about all
these different problems in chemistry
material science is that one when
designs a strategy for the problems of
interest these strategies are typically
very problem specific there's a lot of
heuristics and empirical knowledge that
goes in and this leads to I think the
week really what the weaknesses of
current classical simulation techniques
the in the sense that they're not very
robust you know what works for one
system it may not be the thing you do in
another system okay so where the
possibilities work or my advantage
well I use a well time just flew by okay
well um I guess I'll just give half my
talk so so so I'm gonna go out on a limb
this is my kind of personal opinion so I
I don't so if we ask is there going to
be an electronic structure problem in
some real system where all all methods
just don't give any useful information
they're all classical methods no I I
personally think that's unlikely
I've not seen an example of this in the
domain of chemistry of material science
I think that when one goes into physics
one can create some more artificial
cases that you know not constrained
where you can do this but chemistry and
material science I think is very
difficult but but that's not how we
think about developing methods in the
classical setting I mean we don't try
and find a method that just you know
beats everything else for everything
well I think it's more likely is that
just quantum algorithms I mean they were
just introduced of new axes of
complexity by which we can classify
problems and I think the the thing that
I think it's most interesting to me
is that I think chrome algorithms have
the potential to be more robust in the
sense that if one is looking not to use
as much heuristic information and as
much empirical information that we
currently use in the classical world to
get to these calm solutions you know I
think that is possible in the quantum
realm I mean a simple example of this is
you know if I want to completely reverse
classical method you know exact
organization is the only one you don't
need any empirical information just do
the thing and it's you know it's
exponential in time if you do calm phase
estimate the estimation you know if you
take new if yours include the cost of
state preparation well you know that
arguably that's also exponential in time
but it's certainly not exponential in
memory and so you know that gives you
you know an immediate advantage over
what we do in the classical field okay
so um so then let me now kind of move
and say actually talk about some science
okay so so now I would move to address
the second question about how we can
maybe design some robust algorithms that
we can use on this devices robustness
here doesn't mean robustness necessary
to noise it just means we're bus'ness to
needing to input a lot of empirical
information okay so I'm going to focus
on algorithms for ground States just an
interest of time and you know naturally
one can do face estimation we all know
that just measure the Hamiltonian in
essence and and that will give you the
ground state with some probability if
you do the state preparation and the
issue with phase estimation though it's
a very robust argue in the sense that I
mean robust it's it's not on this
Garrett argument because you need a lot
of control circuits and and at least not
the current list gear so I think
everyone knows that so typically when
one's talking about ground state organs
one's discussing variational techniques
you know q AO a vqe answer and so forth
and these are basically idea of just
optimizing the energy of a unitary
circuit and and this is naturally
something you can do then this guy right
because you can make your circuit very
shallow but I would argue at least to my
taste
you know algorithms of this sort don't
don't push us very far along this
robustness access I mean they may have
other advantages but you know one still
has to design the circuit in practice
especially if you and you have limited
resources you know you can't make the
circuit arbitrarily deep and if you
think
about how you put together and then
secondly you have to do this cast noisy
nonlinear classical optimization you
know so in classical simulations one's
always dealing with nonlinear
optimization and you have to use
empirical knowledge to do it efficiently
but in this case I feel you know one has
the same sort of issue that we mean it's
not worse than classical era bones but
one has the same sort of issue okay so
so what we tried to do was to think of a
different way to get to the ground state
that has a more robust feel to it but
which isn't phase estimation which you
can do in the neck area and to do this
we took some inspiration from how
classical exact algorithms actually work
so if you want to find the ground state
exactly in a classical problem one
technique is to project out the ground
state by doing imagery time evolution so
you just you just cool the system in
some way in some sense down to the
ground state another related technique
is to use things that we call lag shorts
and so and so forth so this is where you
build a space of vectors which are rich
in the extremal vectors by multiplying
the hamiltonian to the state and you
diagnose that hamiltonian the subspace
this can be viewed as a polynomial
approximation of this exponential so so
these are these are sort of robust ways
of getting to the ground state but you
know the classical bottlenecks are that
you have to store the state and that's
exponential you could cost and and you
have to manipulate the stage and that's
exponential cost as well and so what we
try to do is we try to move these
exponential born X onto the quam device
ins with NISP like techniques and this
is what gives us quantum imagery time
evolution and core sanctions so because
there's not a great amount of time I
would just summarize what some of the
properties of these algorithms are
before explaining how they work so you
know I think the nice feature of these
techniques is that they're guaranteed to
reach the ground state so so one doesn't
have to worry about optimization I think
for me that's an important at least
important component and then under
certain conditions the cost of doing an
iteration of this technique is
polynomial in the number of qubits I
mean of course this cannot be true in
general but under under certain
constraints of bounded correlations and
this is true and so then this is an
exponential speed-up over the classical
version of this algorithm and then
finally there no deep circuits and so
it's something that I think we can do it
in this era so so the heart of the
algorithm is just this non unitary
operation which is this expedition magic
time propagation and you no one knows
how to do nonunitary operations on the
chrome computer I mean you can basically
try and take a unitary operator and
define it with some and silly and then
measure and do some post-election and
then you basically get the non non
unitary operator out but you know there
are some issues with that and it's doing
low fees in a row a lot of
post-selection obviously leads to an
exponential failure rate so so we came
up with a different strategy to handle
this nonunitary which is based on the
idea that in a non unitary operator all
we really care about is not the whole
operate itself but just the action of
the operator on the particular state
that we're because we're just trying to
track the the how this non ug operator
guides the state down to the ground
state and so the action of a non you
entry operates in the state is that it
just rotates the state and it rescales
it it's a non you entry operator acting
a state is just a some rescaling factor
times that you ensure in the states and
so the basic idea is that we do some
type of tomography in order to get out
this rescaling constant and what this
unitary really is
okay so I'll illustrate how we can do
that for one qubit and then and then I'm
just going to say that's possible since
I rent we're gonna run out of time
so in one qubit for example you know
this is an action of the Imagi time
operator for very small time on the
state and it maps them to a constant
times a new entry time to state and you
can see immediately this constant is
just a normalization constant of this
object so I can just do some
measurements in some disk like way you
know it's measuring expectation values
to get this number
and then similarly this unitary here is
made is parametrized by three angles and
so I just need to do three measurements
in the state to get the three angles and
so we just carry out three measurements
and solve some linear equations and then
we can get the three angles out so we
can reconstruct the entry in this way
and so this follows with more cubits in
the general case and you basically try
to rise your Hamiltonian apply it to a
state and then ever state a certain
length of correlations in it then we do
tomography over the correlation size of
that of the state and we can recompile
in your algebra reconstruct the
constants and the unitary okay so I'll
just show some results we're running out
of time so just to show that this could
be done on a next device then this was
an implementation we did on a spin one
so this was really a very old chip of
Righetti I mean I don't think we get see
themselves would say this was a
particularly good chip but it's a trip
and you know this is just to show you
that one can in fact propagate in a
mattre time to get the ground state
after some number of time steps there
are very large error bars because this
is drift in the device if you run it
several times you get different results
and that's the error buzzer and I didn't
have I didn't tell you exactly how this
can be done but you can use this
algorithm also to do statistical
mechanics and so is that we computed
here some thermal expectation values so
so I think that this is an interesting
algorithm in the NIST gira in the sense
that if one does resolve estimates it's
it's actually very resource efficient
both in terms of the circuit depth and
in terms of the number of measurements
you need to reconstruct the unitary here
are some sort of estimates just on some
very simple systems right so this is
like a foresight Heisenberg model in a
six site Heisenberg model and we
compared it to the hardware efficient
variation of one set and we we counted
the number of measurements we needed to
converge the vqe to one percent of the
exact energy and the number we needed to
converge kite to one percent of the
energy and you notice here that you know
there's sturdy mark far fewer
measurements that are used in kite and
it gets this discrepancy gets bigger as
the system size increases and that's
really the cost of optimization at least
our experience with vqe is that if you
go to more and more sites then the cost
the time to you know the number of
optimization steps to automate a circuit
also increase
so potentially this is something that we
can scale to large nest devices and you
know here are just some kind of resource
estimates or some some ideas of how this
might perform so we take the minimal
formulation of this algorithm we one
sees that it doesn't degrade in terms of
its accuracy as a number of size
increases and that one can get to quite
a good answer
just with a small number of time steps
okay so this is just applying four steps
of the magic time evolution it's a very
shallow circuit and then secondly is it
robust with noise well I mean you know
of course it gets worse as you add noise
but it doesn't get completely it doesn't
completely fail so these are highlighted
here someone into acuity polarizing
channels and one you know introduces
some error and the energy but it's not
too large okay so so based on these
estimates then if one was doing a
simulation 50 cubits to do four time
steps like this then this is twenty four
layers of C knots which may or may not
be doable but presumably will be doable
at some point in the future okay so I
think I've used up with my time right so
I won't really talk about physical
quorum supremacy it was just really just
one slide and I just want to say that
Bella Sergey myself and Mario wrote a
review article which is intended to give
some perspective on calm computing in
chrome arrogance meaningful chemistry
and material scientists but it might be
interesting for you guys to read to get
to see what's like you know from the
other side thank you attention
I talked about periodic systems of
transition metals like no sodium RG I
mean you could apply it to transition
valves but I don't think it in periodic
systems for example using codes we
already have you can run such
simulations but I don't think it's very
the method of choice there yeah so so
the answer is the code there are codes
to do it but I there are other classical
techniques which are more relevant for
that case yeah when you're computing the
Unitarian getting the coefficients for
the unitary yeah did you use a classical
linear optimizer or were you doing it by
performing the measurements there's no
so you so well I mean you you've
performed some measurements you
construct a linear algebra problem ax
equals B which you solve on the
classical device right just by exactly
than your algebra
yes I wanted to ask
okay so it's a roughly speaking I'm just
trying to say that I think most states
that we usually think about are too easy
so the problem that I'm aware of in
chemical physics is is that it's closely
related to supremacy is the onset of
calm chaos so if you go into molecular
vibrations you go up into the spectrum
there's a question you know at what
energy scale do you actually get in the
chaotic regime and this is something
that was studied a lot in the 80s but of
course only in small systems because you
know there's a limit to what you could
simulate numerically and so what the key
thing is to formulate studying this
question in a way that can be done in
the Niska area and I think that can be
done really by trying to determine the
unitary that transforms you to the
energy basis in a variational way and
this gives you went by optimizing this
this object here which is something
people do in studies of many-body
localization they try and optimize this
to diagonalize the Hamiltonian you could
try and do this on a qualm computer this
gives you a metric you can get a number
here if Cuong does better than costco
then you can call that super NC right so
that's that's always going to be an
exponential somewhere right around state
convergence of the imaginary time that's
it probably depends on the gap right
it's not not it depends on a more
complicated quantity than the gap but
yeah you can get some idea but that's a
reasonable starting point for different
systems or large systems well I mean if
you study a gapless system then you know
you have to project a more imaginary
time it converges exponentially in the
size of the gap I mean the same thing is
true in classical algorithms you need to
take you know so so you could imagine if
this were not an issue you know then you
could just get to ground states you know
in finite amounts of time so there must
be problems where this gap issue is is
is a problem it's a little bit like
adiabatic algorithms you know there
there is a similar it's not exactly the
same but to constrain it but I'd argue
that you don't need to think about it I
mean you just run your algorithm you
just run it a bit longer and see if it
changes and that's the sense in which
it's you mean is it the case that
everything is gapless yeah so this isn't
this isn't the same as the ada bag
oregon where you don't require any
crossing of states right but it's
certainly not true that everything is
gapless outside one dimension yeah I
mean so you know there's always one can
always find did I can always define
cases of course where this is
exponential cost this is not a statement
that one can always get to the ground
state in polynomial causing that would
violate a lot of things we think about
complexity the question is just whether
this is true in typical material right
and I don't and I would argue that's not
true in typical material actually most
materials you don't go through any comp
I mean you go maybe just through a
disorder to order phase transition but
you don't go in the correlation deck we
don't blow up in certain types of phase
transitions right they have to be
second-order
yes so you're making these strong
correlation length assumptions on all
the states and in your algorithm for the
tomography stuff to be sort of fast
along the path right yeah so it's like
no second order phase transition is for
it to be an exact algorithm with this
polynomial guarantee so I'm worried if
the states that you encounter in this
algorithm really do satisfy that
assumption that's exactly the sort of
property that would lend the algorithm
to be able to be possibly possibly
simulated yes yes I mean this is of
course always a concern all right I mean
so so whenever you find some some
special subclass that seems to be you
know efficient classically quantumly you
know even with factoring right then
you'll be like well but are you really
sure there isn't a a better class going
to do so so so I do I mean what we did
in the paper was we try to identify you
know various types of class groups that
you might use for example let's just
simulate on the finite chunk of stuff
you're right that's one way if you have
a fire correlation length you might
expect to be able to get an answer for
the whole piece but you can construct
counter examples where that cask Oregon
will fail well it would appear that this
one that's not right so but indeed
that's always you always have to think
about these concerns
I mean that you can start from anything
yeah I mean well we we haven't done that
type of optimization but my argument for
why I like this type of technique is
because you don't have to think too much
about how you do it so indeed we start
from very trivial product states other
inputs days
[Applause]